nous avons décidé avec le président de
la chambre d'agriculture de la région
ile de france christophe hillairet que
créer de mettre sur pied un programme
alimentaire régionale pour venir en aide
des plus démunis sur la base des besoins
qui vont être exprimées par les
associations à la banque alimentaire la
région financera l'achat de produits
agricoles et alimentaires auprès des
agriculteurs franciliens qui prendront à
leur charge l'organisation du sourcing
voilà je me réjouis de ce partenariat
exemplaire entre notre collectivité et
le monde agricole qui est fidèle aux
valeurs qui sont les siennes responsable
pendant la crise et solidaire dans ses
effets dramatiques